KREIDER THREE ASSIST IN THAT
GAME AND RANGERS FOUND A WAY
LINEUP.
THEY HARD WORK
JACOB TROUBACE-OFF.
HE'LL PULL IT ARIZONA.
LAST SEASON, HE WASBEHIND.
SCHNEIDER IS THERE.
BUT HE LEAVES.
2:29.
SCHMALTZ.
KELLER TO THE NET.
A SAVE IT
STAYS IN THE ZONE.
THEN  FOR A LANE.
THAT IS DEFLECTED OFF THE GLASS.
PLAYED INZIBANEJAD FINDS IT AGA.
TROUBA ANDJAD?
FABULOUS MOVE BY HIM.
THEN HEFRONT!
SAVE!
A BIG SAVE ON BFF THE
REBOUND AND IT WENT SUPPORT ON .
THEY KEEP WORKING IT TO THERIN !
THEY SCORE! SOON AS HE GOES TO ,
THE SHOT GOES TO HISIN.
A PASS FROM PANARIN AND THEY
SCORE AGAIN! PUCK.
HE TRIEDO TROUBA.
BIG SPOT!
SCORE!P WITH IT.
EVENTUALLY IT COMES BACK TO
TROUBA ON THE OTHTH
THEY STARTED SLOWLY.
DID NOTR!
HE SCORED! JUMPS ON THE
HE SCORED! JUMPS ON THE
HE SCORED! JUMPS ON THE